ahora trabajaremos con un ejemplo más
interesante luego trataremos de analizar
el campo vectorial y esperemos que esto
haga todo un poco más tangible y más
claro entonces digamos que la velocidad
del fluido de sus partículas en
determinado punto del plano xy digamos
está dado en la dirección x por
x cuadrada - - - 3x y vamos a sumarle 2
esto en la dirección horizontal más de
cuadrada menos 3 y más 2 y esto en la
dirección vertical verdad en la
dirección del vector j esto lo hace muy
sencillo porque la componente horizontal
simplemente depende de x y la componente
vertical solo depende de ella ahora
calculemos la divergencia de este campo
vectorial entonces después vamos a ver
cómo es la gráfica de este campo y ver
cómo entender finalmente lo que es la
divergencia entonces tomamos la derivada
parcial de la primera componente
respecto de x y que nos da bueno
realmente todo depende de x así que es
simplemente su derivada verdad entonces
tendremos 2x menos 3
y ahora hay que sumar la derivada
parcial de la segunda componente
respecto de iu pero otra vez todo
depende de la variable ya así que
simplemente es la derivada verdad que es
dos menos tres
y bueno esto simplemente al simplificar
tenemos que la divergencia debe que es
nuestro campo vectoriales 2 x + 2 y
menos menos 3 muy bien ahora antes de
que lo gráfica que vamos a analizar cómo
es esta función un poco primero que nada
vamos a ver cómo se se mira el campo
vectorial entonces cuáles son los puntos
interesantes bueno unos puntos
interesantes es cuando las componentes
se anulan así que cuando es igual a cero
la componente en x bueno realmente
podremos reescribir esa componente de la
siguiente forma ve nuestro campo
vectorial es x menos 1 por x menos 2
verdad simplemente estamos reescribiendo
al factorizar y la segunda componente le
escribimos también como ge -1 por que
menos 2 y esto pues en la dirección
es decir en la dirección del vector j
entonces la primera componente es igual
a cero cuando x es igual a 1 o bien
cuando x es igual a 2 correcto de igual
forma la segunda componente se anula
cuando hoy es igual a 1 o bien y es
igual a 2
entonces el campo completo se anula
cuando pasa algunos o más bien cuando
pasa que x es igual a 1 y es igual a 1 o
x es igual a 1 y es igual a 2 oye o x es
igual a 2 y la 1 hoy es igual a equis
que es igual a 2 entonces estos son los
puntos donde la magnitud de la velocidad
de nuestro líquido del fluido es igual a
y eso lo vamos a distinguir en la
gráfica en unos momentos entonces vamos
a decidir en primer lugar en qué puntos
la divergencia es cero entonces déjenme
déjenme borrar esta esta parte donde
encontramos la los puntos de donde se
anula el campo vectorial
para hacer de nuevo la cuenta así que
vamos a averiguar cuándo es la
divergencia en qué puntos es igual a 0
correcto entonces la divergencia es 12 x
+ 2 - - - que yo ya vi tuve un error
verdad porque tenía dos veces menos 3
aquí esto es menos 6 verdad vaya este
ese es mi mayor defecto no sé creo sumar
ni restar al parecer es bueno en fin
corrigiendo el error tenemos que la
divergencia es 2 x 2 10 menos 6 y
queremos que esto sea igual a cero vamos
a simplificar esto un poco porque
podemos dividir entre 2 toda la ecuación
verdad y entonces nos queda x + menos 3
igual a cero de donde x + es igual a 3 y
sabemos que esta adecuación de una recta
pero vamos a llevarlo a la forma igual a
mx más b que es
más sencillo de analizar y de analizar
cómo es la línea y tendremos que ya es
igual a 3 x así que a lo largo de esta
línea la divergencia del campo vectorial
se anula y entonces a lo largo de la
línea ye igual a 3 - x si estamos por
encima de esta línea entonces tendremos
que ya es mayor que 3 - x pero son
arriba de esa línea es decir cuando es
mayor que 3 - x la divergencia es
positiva por otro lado cuando estemos
debajo es decir que ye sea menor que 3 -
x la divergencia será negativa que bien
pude haberlo hecho multiplicando por un
menos y resolviendo para ayer verdad eso
encontraría la divergencia negativa así
que creo que ya hemos hecho todo el
análisis que se puede vamos a echar un
vistazo a la gráfica para ver si es
consistente con nuestra intuición de lo
que es la divergencia
entonces espero que puedan ver esto este
es el campo vectorial graficado no tengo
mucho espacio para mostrarlo pero creo
recordar quién es el campo que es x
cuadrada menos 3 x + 2 por un lado y ya
cuadrada menos 3 yemas 2 entonces
averiguaremos cuando los componentes de
xy de ye son iguales a 0 y entonces
dijimos o bien tenemos el punto 11 que
es este de aquí también este los
vectores son 0 en ese en ese punto del
campo vectorial verdad entonces todos
están apuntando hacia adentro
entonces eso implica que tenemos que la
divergencia es negativa también tenemos
el 12 y aquí podemos ver que la magnitud
también se acerca mucho mucho a 0 cuando
nos acercamos al punto y el otro punto
es 21 una vez más se hacen muy pequeñas
las flechitas acercándonos ahí por lo
cual es coherente con lo que habíamos
obtenido la otra cosa interesante que
dijimos es bueno cuando la divergencia
es cero así que la divergencia es cero
equivale a la recta de igual a 3x ok
entonces la recta igual a 3x inicia
déjenme venir algo así más o menos como
estoy marcando con él con el puntero en
esta recta la divergencia es cero y si
realmente nos fijamos en el gráfico
tiene sentido digo ya no puedo dibujar
encima de él pero si dibujáramos un
círculo por aquí entonces supongamos que
está en esa recta en la igual a 3 - x
tendríamos una cantidad de partículas
iguales que entran de las que salen
del lado derecho entran y del lado
izquierdo salen pero la misma cantidad
entonces si nos vamos a la parte
inferior si nos vamos de aquí sobre la
línea por ejemplo entonces vemos que hay
muy poquitas partículas que entran pero
también hay muy poquitas que se alejan
sé que es difícil de ver pero pero
realmente aquí se aprecia que la
divergencia es cero por este argumento
ahora analicemos algunos de los otros
puntos hasta aquí calculamos que la
divergencia pues es positiva verdad en
cualquier punto arbitrario sí sí
dibujáramos un círculo alrededor veremos
que del lado izquierdo de este círculo
no puedo aprovechar muy bien este
gráfico no se ve bien pero en realidad
digamos que la el cuadrado es mi región
muy bien entonces veamos que los
vectores en la izquierda son más grandes
que superan a los factores a los
vectores perdón
que están del lado derecho verdad que
son los que entran entonces estoy
convirtiendo en menos densa esta región
no podría decir que las partículas son
divergentes verdad y tiene sentido
porque tengo una divergencia positiva de
este lado si nos vamos del otro lado
digamos seleccionamos un cuadrito no un
cuadrito de estos vemos que los vectores
que ingresan a ella la magnitud de ellos
es mucho más grande que de los que salen
correcto entonces en cualquier tiempo
dado tenemos que en este cuadrito se
vuelve más denso o bien que tenemos una
divergencia negativa en sí que están
realmente convergiendo entonces está
ocurriendo algo muy muy muy importante
en estos dos puntos lo que en el punto 2
1 así que vemos que en este punto en la
dirección que realmente está
convergiendo verdad porque por encima de
ella igual a 1 las flechas apuntan hacia
abajo y por debajo de ese punto las
flechas apuntan hacia arriba por lo que
en la dirección y en realidad hay
convergencia tienen
negativa ahora aquí pase en la dirección
x bueno ahí realmente está pasando todo
lo contrario porque bueno en el punto la
divergencia es cero pero fíjense que por
encima están entrando y por debajo
también y por lo tanto como las
partículas están siendo desviadas por
hacia afuera en el eje x en términos
netos entre ambas dimensiones pues
realmente la divergencia es cero verdad
y eso es porque ye igual a 3 menos x es
el conjunto de puntos donde la
divergencia es nula ahora esto significa
que las cosas están fluyendo hacia
afuera cuando la tasa de cambio es
positivo eso por ejemplo en esta región
verdad así que tiene sentido si nuestras
derivadas parciales son positivas eso
significa que la magnitud de nuestro
vector se hace cada vez más y más
grandes para este tipo de puntos verdad
así que si la magnitud de nuestros
vectores es cada vez más grande para
valores de xy de iu entonces los
vectores del generados por el campo
vectorial aumentan también en magnitud
así que si denotamos alguna región
acotada por ejemplo los vectores que
salen por la derecha son cada vez más
grandes que los que entran por la
izquierda espero no te hayas confundido
mucho me he quedado sin tiempo así que
nos vemos luego